speaking of birthdays and lebron yes
today somebody has a birthday today that
we want to recognize we don't do this
every day every day in a birthday show
but some people you do have to stop
and wish them happy birthday take it
away uh
he comes from he hails from uh
french link indiana six nine
uh the game's original point forward
larry bird so larry joe bird uh today
is his birthday and i don't just bring
it up so you could say oh wow happy
birthday larry joe bird
it it's more of
this is an example of how how quickly
our our best of conversations
kind of come and go like still nobody
has done this
since larry larry bird did it in the mid
80s
three straight mvp awards
so let's stop for a second in the
mid-80s
the baddest man on the planet in a
league that
included magic johnson
man kareem isaiah young michael
young yeah but and the baddest man
walking
was that guy and not just in terms of
skills
not just in terms of trash talk he
fights you he was the original anthony
mason you couldn't take larry bird
nowhere he will fight you
he can fight he can fight he can board
um he can he can do everything
everything and here's he
this is what's so interesting and i do
believe i'm one of those people
who believes that even if you go back to
the 50s or 60s i think you can you can
take the best players
the best not any of them but just like
the top three top five players from any
era
and they can make a ball anywhere larry
bird
i think fact-check me if you want to but
off the top of my head i think the most
three-pointers he ever
attempted in his career was like 200
something okay old three-pointers he
ever attempted
career totals in his career
unfortunately 237
in 87 88. okay but to your point
early in his career you went one two
three four straight years attempting
under
80. yeah yeah because it was different
yeah it was a different game
so they were drilled they were drilled
differently than players are now players
are now
if you don't have if you don't have a
three-point shot well what are you doing
out there
take that mid-range game out of here
yeah give me a three-pointer
can you imagine larry bird at that size
and with that passing ability
and his and his great free throw
shooting
and his rebounding all the things he
could
he he would be one of those guys bored
come down
papa three yeah be perfect in today's
game but i i i think we should
keep in mind we talk about the best
all-time players that we're we're always
oh i don't forget it
i don't forget the people off the list
oh well no check this out
it was only a couple of years ago this i
mean i'll say this because we always
keep it 100 and you know i'll admit
not just if i'm wrong i'll admit
if my opinion was outdated it was only a
couple of years ago two
three years ago maybe four i don't
remember maybe it was uh
it might have been you know uh the
comeback from 3-1
i would not let lebron start in my
all-time
starting five in terms of like strict
positions
larry bird was my three and i wouldn't
get i would not come off of that it took
me forever
to let lebron come off the bench and
start ahead of larry bird
in my all-time starting five that is the
regard with which i hold
larry legend i mean because people were
like oh
lebron's better than bird i'd be like
what because at the time lebron had
unleashed this devastating outside shot
he has right
right who knew lebron would get better
as his career went on i'm like larry
bird was a
brilliant pastor defense that's where
that's where lebron is better though
well yeah yeah
individual defense but byrd within the
system and even individually
defended fairly well he defended he
defended look man don't don't don't
start don't do this
i'm not saying he was no stopper but
larry bird did his job
shooting even though three-pointing
wasn't a big part of the game
passing scoring i mean i was a bird guy
but i've since obviously come off that
the king
that's his spot the king could start
whatever he wants in an all-time
starting five
i'm just saying i'm echoing your point
about
the other great larry bird and the
cultural touchstone that larry bird was
michael
people how many people have tried to
hate on larry bird
as the great white hope or some
overrated white boy back in the 80s
it was like you know it was a cultural
controversy
it was actually players didn't want to
give it to him yeah it was actually
i was verbalized between you know dennis
robin and isaiah thomas yes
yes yes they talked about it yeah that
was uh in the uh and then he ate their
lunch
the dude said i wanna i wanna save my
left hand for the lakers
so i'm gonna play lefty today i mean you
who talk trash better than larry bird
you know but this is what i like about
him too away from the court
and this is this is good this is good
for this is a good example
not just for basketball players but but
for for musicians and writers and
everybody else
larry bird is not one of those cats who
would just say
in my day dot dot dot that's really
annoying that's like you want to get old
no you want to get old in a hurry
just say in my day everything was better
and everything now is terrible okay
that's what that's what a lot of people
uh who played in a certain era played
music did movies whatever
they kind of hold on to that larry bird
was one of the first people to say
when uh michael jordan when they all got
together for the dream team
and magic and michael were talking trash
and michael said
hey magic it's my era now.
and magic was saying what are you
talking about larry said he's right
he's right larry when they asked larry
about his favorite players now he'll
mention lebron
he'll say lebron might be the best one
of them all he's that dude
happy birthday larry bird appreciate you
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch
us 3-5 p.m eastern time
on peacock appreciate you